foreign
looking at the title and I'm pretty sure
you're pumped up to see my list of top
20 overpowered main characters this list
won't be ranking them because quite
frankly it's an exercise in futility
trying to rank some characters against
each other this is especially true when
we reach the upper tears oh and
obviously spoilers abound but I'm trying
to keep things not as blatant for those
who still want to be surprised when
watching said shows and lastly we're
talking actual combat skills and
arsenals here so no super Geniuses or
the like sorry Sora and Shiro let's see
if your favorite characters make the
list then
sign off the list we have Kirito
possibly one of the faces of overpowered
protagonists in the early part of the
2010s you know we're in for a list of
Titans if this guy is at the very bottom
indeed Kirito has a whole arsenal of
skills at his disposal being an expert
gamer has its perks and in the world of
virtual reality few can match Kirito and
let's not even talk about that
embarrassing stint at the first part of
ordinal scale bigger the bottom of the
list means that he's relatively tame
compared to everyone else indeed Kirito
is not Invincible by any means and
whilst he's got a whole bag of tricks
and access to some of the most
overpowered hacks he still plays within
the system he's at his strongest at the
end of alicization but even that final
fight is something that he with all of
the Godlike system Powers he had control
of couldn't overcome on his own
foreign
let's take time to thank today's sponsor
snowbreak containment Zone it combines a
cool looking sci-fi world and setting
with some exciting gameplay that will
always keep you on the edge of your
seats I'm talking fast-paced action that
puts a lot of focus on skill combos your
team composition and challenging foes
that require you to constantly adjust
your plays on the Fly given the sheer
Arsenal and the number of characters for
you to use and Tinker with there's room
for Limitless possibilities and if
you've been here before in the
pre-release got some good news the
team's taken some of the feedback and
added a lot of improvements since then
so you can join a much improved version
of the game gameplay runs way smoother
now and a new cover system to help out
against the more challenging bosses
creating a much more Dynamic combat
experience for both rookies and Veterans
of the genre to enjoy best of all open
beta testers get an SSR for free after
completing the fifth chapter of the
story not only that though they also get
this really cool sniper rifle and a Yao
skin after a 14 day login event another
cool thing is that this game supports
cross-platform play and that allowed
allow me to spend a lot of Fun hours on
end with my friends who usually play on
a PC snow break containment Zone seeks
to combine a lot of what we love about
anime the Sci-Fi World fast blitzing
action top tier waifu characters and a
lot of customization and design options
download snow break containment zone now
and claim your free SSR character just
use my gift code and follow the links in
the description to take the plunge into
the containment zones we can't have a
list of overpowered characters featuring
Kirito without including his partner in
crime tatsuya
oh
I remember those days when Dengue key
would keep promoting Sao and mahoka
together it's not a surprise the company
kept going with that pairing the two
shows aired quite close to each other
and both starred and Lead that's rather
aloof and overpowered in their own
Universe however tatsuya definitely
trumps Kirito in terms of being
overpowered this is a guy who's done it
all master strategist genius engineer
and unmatched Soldier this is a guy who
literally can look a sniper in the eye
and win a shootout using his trusty
handgun a guy who can revive others
create and fire off the equivalent of a
nuclear weapon from the Comforts of a
base and even bring himself back from
the dead mahoka is simply full of his
exploits and it's quite amazing how it's
this kind of overpowered monster that's
being underestimated there's nothing
that can stop a determined that sueya
and if you're one of the Unfortunate
Souls thinking of harming his sister
you've just signed your death warranty
I do
[Music]
and while we're on the topic of the
2010s we move on to a less expected
overpowered character with Madoka ganome
[Music]
back in those days Morocco was really
big however there's not a lot of people
who had the pink protagonist as the
Undisputed favorite amongst the girls I
mean that's to be expected that's what
the majority of the story that we see
maroka ends up being one of the most
passive main characters in a show full
of action girls but once we get to the
latter parts and the Mysteries start
getting resolved there's no doubt that
if there's a character that's crazy
powerful in this show it's Madoka I
think I've done enough spoiling as it is
so I implore you to watch this
masterpiece of the 2010s but if you have
watched the show already I'm sure you'll
agree with me when I say that this cute
friendly girl is quite literally Godlike
in power in terms of power scaling in
the TV series nothing can come close to
Madoka beware the nice ones indeed
Annabella
why not proceed with another product of
the era accelerator is pretty cool right
foreign
Series has been very influential in my
growth as an anime fan it's all the rage
in the 2000s to the early 20s and while
it's super Niche these days it did bring
us all the way to the excellent railgun
t a few years ago accelerator's someone
who's come a long way with a character
development Arc that spans multiple
seasons and spin-offs one thing that
hasn't changed is the fact that he's
overpowered as hell the title of being
the strongest Academy City expert isn't
for show no not by any means his powers
may seem simple at first glance being
the ability to redirect attacks if we're
going to oversimplify in layman's terms
however when you do see the implications
of that and how he applies it to great
effect it is nothing short of amazing oh
and he still gets a slew of other cool
Powers as the show proceeds so there's
that too here's to one of the craziest
overpowered characters in the show's
insanely large cast of characters
talk about
the light novels without mentioning one
of the most popular ones from around
that time No Game No Life oops well I'm
looking at for this entry is actually
the predecessor the far less popular
problem children are coming from another
world and its protagonist izayoi
foreign
was the cool new trend in town There's
this lesser known predecessor to No Game
No Life izayoi's powers are relatively
simple if I told you it's just super
strength at its core would you believe
that this guy's that overpowered now
what if I told you it's like index's
Dorma and has the power to just break
through everyone else's powers yeah
that's what we're talking about right
izayo uses this power to great effect in
the series and he wastes no time making
a strong first impression defeating a
water God just as soon as he gets
transported into little garden combining
that overpowered skill with his wits and
intellect and you can see clearly why
these guys are forced to be reckoned
with
Jane Mori gets the honor of resuming the
list
gin Mori is an interesting case he
doesn't win all his on-screen fights for
one but he's one hell of a fighter and
in the long run especially given his
revealed identity in the latter part of
the story we eventually saw how broken
he can really be in a show like God of
high school which features as wild of a
martial arts Tony as they can go that's
saying something the series does a great
job showcasing his protagonists Godly
powers and with each Revelation on what
Jinn is locked within himself the power
scaling just goes through the roof in
human talent and match fighting skill at
a heart that just refuses to give up not
to mention The Monkey King powers that
push their things past their limits I do
think that Jin Mori deserves some love
despite the anime adaptation of God of
high school having his fair share of
issues
in a similar vein let's talk Mash
how have you been enjoying Marshall so
far it's a pretty fun show all around
right it's got a newcomer to the club of
overpowered protagonists in Mash who
apparently took lessons from his
numerous predecessors who can overcome
magic with physical tools they took some
training from hell but here we have a
character who may as well be using
magical powers with how impressive his
techniques look one of the fun Parts in
watching Master is to see Mash's
creativity in action his entire arsenal
of physical techniques is truly a joy to
witness and I just can't get enough of
how over the top everything is it takes
a certain level of special to push one's
physical gifts beyond their limit but if
you're up for things like that Mash burn
dead is your guy
for better follow-up to mash than the
man himself saitama
if we're talking about a character
stands in the scaling of his own
Universe I know that side armor should
be way further into the list is the
epitome of overpowered even in his world
of superheroes and super villains I
don't think anyone in the one punch man
world can outdo him who only needs one
punch literally to defeat his enemies
however I feel talking about sidearma's
great follow-up to mash due to the
similar nature of their fighting styles
and Origins saitama's entire schtick is
that he's the Pinnacle of training from
hell and what happens when someone gets
pushed Beyond his limits or at least
that's what we're made to believe in
that he attained everything through
sheer training and putting himself
through hell for a year so watch out
Scythe armor on any ordinary day may
seem Goofy and listless however beyond
that exterior lies the strongest hero in
the universe
mob then comes to mind after saitama
Frankly Speaking it feels like a
downgrade in power scaling going from
saithama to mob even if they're quite
similar characters similar disposition
with a similar heart for justice and
both are just as impressive in their own
series while mob doesn't always defeat
everyone in one hit he's also pretty
much one of the most powerful espers in
the world of mob psycho capable of
turning into an engine of Destruction at
a moment's notice you just have to push
the wrong buttons and that's something I
highly highly advise against it Bob has
repeatedly proven that he's just crazy
overpowered in his own series and few
can challenge him when his ultimate form
comes out that's something that you have
to witness for yourself from unassuming
a nice hero to a possible monster within
it's pretty cool how the same Creator
managed to take two characters with
quite similar dispositions and make them
so unique from each other
while we have epic stories to follow
from saithama and mobs anime psyche's
anime takes a way more light-hearted
approach
yourself
psyche is in a lot of ways very similar
to mob both have psychic powers and both
have resolved to put these powers to
good use however the way their anime are
presented are completely different and
it takes a way more comedic turn for the
disastrous life of psyche K regardless I
think they're going the root of comedy
and parody is a pretty good way to
present a character who's pretty much a
god amongst Mortals while there are
other characters with powers in the
series not a lot of them can hold a
candle to psyche in terms of power or
just a sheer Arsenal seriously psyche's
list of powers is insane and can put a
number of isakai Heroes to shame
teleportation shape-shifting cloning you
name it so if you're up to seeing our
protagonists get put into compromising
situations with those powers that he
never wanted disastrous life of psychi K
is a good title for some quick laughs
from assassination classroom
assassination classroom is a pretty
simple show in a nutshell a group of
students must work together in order to
assassinate their teacher some big
octopus assassin in order to save the
world now it's simple enough on paper
nigh impossible in practice though I
mean Goro Sensei is as tough as it goes
in the world of assassination classroom
pretty much a character who's impossible
to kill due to all the abilities and
Powers he possesses whatever plan you
have in mind you know for sure that God
of Sensei is gonna have a way out of it
you can't outspeed him you can't
outsmart him and you sure as hell can't
beat him in straight up fighting so
what's left there's a reason even the
resources and the power of the world's
governments and the strongest foes with
Supernatural Powers find themselves at
their Wits End trying to tackle the Coro
Sensei problem and the journey to finish
that insane task is what makes
assassination classrooms such a fun
watch
polarizing webtoon adaptation is nobless
but hey it gave us another overpowered
character in Rye
not much needs to be said about Nobles
as an anime it's not exactly a great
adaptation and coming months after God
of high school that's a bummer still if
there's one thing that the anime at
least showcased it's just how powerful
the main character Rye is rye comes from
a lineage of vampiric beings but he's
just a noble he's the titular Nobles the
strongest member of the entire race
serving as the protector judge and
executioner for the group of powerful
beings as such Why didn't disappoint in
his performance noblesse has a lot of
instances where he flexes his power and
asserts his will against all who oppose
him is the kind of character whose mere
mention can send others trembling in
fear if we ever get to see more Nobles
anime I don't expect the status quo to
ever change he stands as the strongest
being in the entire series and we all
better get used to that moving forward
after right we have what I feel is the
Japanese counterpart arnos
it feels just right to have arnos here
as his overall feel as a character feels
super similar to Ryan underworld Lord
main characters who spent time
immemorial in deep Slumber waking up to
find a world completely different from
the one that left behind now the Angela
world full of Mortals who are underneath
them simply outclassed in any way
imaginable just like right arnos holds
unimaginable power that makes him pretty
much God amongst men this is someone who
literally tosses a castle like it was
nothing or can kill without even putting
his hands on someone only to revive them
just to repeat the process all over
again it's pretty crazy and the only big
difference is that arnos does all of
that while acting pretty smug himself
then again with how ahead he is in the
competition I don't see why arnos
wouldn't start to get arrogant when he
got power that great it's good to be
able to flex and bask in the moment
[Applause]
yes
let's take a trip to the bygone days for
a while where Alucard lurks and captures
the heart of teenagers everywhere
foreign
[Music]
back in the 2000s It just fits his
character so much being this hyper
badass who doesn't pull punches slaying
Supernatural threads left and right as
one of the most coolest imaginable
anti-heroes there's so much about
Alucard that encapsulates the rebel
culture of the 2000s and of course he
gets the Lion's Share of broken powers
in the Helsing universe and one thing
Alucard does so well is to make those
Powers look as intimidating as possible
aruga is a type of character who really
lets his opponents know they're just
gonna get destroyed and there's no way
around him he's cruel he's merciless and
he makes it known that you're completely
helpless against him just the embodiment
of cool if you're one of those 2000s
teens
so we do
so gunky a perennial favorite of anime
fans from the old days in the 2010s is
JoJo it's got a lot of overpowered
characters there but I think it's time
that we give Diono some love
do you all know is the character that
doesn't get talked about as much
compared to a lot of big guns in the
JoJo universe so that's why for today
we'll be giving him his flowers any more
than deserves him JoJo has no shortage
of crazy powerful Powers but gold
experience at its full power really
should be in the upper echelons it holds
power over life and can deliver some big
time pummeling when needed however its
true potential gets unlocked when it
evolves into gold experience Requiem
it's here that its control over life
gets pushed into overdrive being capable
of outright erasing anything and
trapping foes in a death loop it's
pretty mind-blowing just thinking about
it so how's that for perspective
no it's coming overpowered character
list it's time to take a tour to issakai
world and we start off with Hajime
is a show that stands as a
quintessential example of Revenge power
fantasy Underdog boy gets betrayed Falls
to near death and survives through sheer
edgy grit becoming a monster stronger
than anything the world's ever seen I
mentioned parts of this phenomenon in
aluka's entry and I see Hajime as some
sort of modern counterpart in that edgy
teenager role model appeal and he does
this in an admittedly creative way yes
he ate monsters to attain the level of
power he had but a lot of it has to do
with the genius use of the supposed weak
power he's given transmutation Hajime
may not like it given that he primarily
just uses his two guns but he's an
entire arsenal of magical weapons and he
knows how to use all of them to their
full potential empowering his way
through hordes of enemies and striking
back against the world that betrayed him
moving on we have the plaque slime
rimaru
just like Hajime rimaru had his humble
beginnings he had to crawl his way to
the top taking it one step at a time as
he started off as a lowly slime with
each monster he consumes he gets more
abilities added to the ever-growing
Arsenal simple but boy the results speak
for themselves looking at his state
right now as well as the length and
influence he holds you can tell he's
been through a long long journey at this
point people have been crowning him the
most overpowered character who can blame
them he's now become a being that's
transcended all existence we're talking
Universe destroying potential and here's
the catch he's actually not even at his
Peak if we're talking anime continuity
light novel rimuru has surpassed
everything you can see in anime form and
let's not even mention his web novel
forming the same breath
foreign
trip with irons
we can't exactly compare rimaru to irons
in a straight up battle since their
worlds operate differently however few
can match the sheer fear and presence
eins carries if there's an overpowered
character who certainly looks the part
irons is undoubtedly one of the best
ones in the whole isekai genre eins
looks every part of a super scary
Overlord pun intended there who can
easily crush the entire world under his
finger should he find the desire to he's
impervious to damage is a master
combatant of wheel spells that turns
enemy armies into fodder Overlord
another show isn't solely carried by
eins and people watching him wreck face
but it certainly is a super fun part of
it
[Applause]
we approach the end of the list and I'd
like to feature Wang Ling
that's just something with Chinese
eyepiece and they're ridiculously
overpowered characters it's a thing that
they just love even more so than the
Japanese the way I see it for those who
aren't so attuned with the Chinese anime
scene however wangling is probably the
name you might be familiar with daily
life of immortal King is easily
available through platforms like Netflix
after all as for one himself I mean what
can I say this character profile states
that he's The Reincarnation of an
immortal Emperor whose traversed Realms
Gathering Power and becoming even more
Transcendent with each one even when he
wasn't at his Peak he was capable of
demolishing demon Lords with basic kicks
and the like now well you can take a
look at this Wiki screenshot yourself
and come to terms that such a being is
trapped in the body of a high school boy
daily life of immortal King feels like a
Chinese anime inspired by saiki K or mob
psycho so it makes sense that its main
character takes on a similar trajectory
foreign
last but not least we have Goku
is Goku the strongest main character in
anime can it be a match against all
those crazy issakai protagonists I mean
that's debatable we can never know for
real there's a reason why the whole but
can he beat Goku joke has become a
cultural trademark in the anime
Community Goku's not the strongest being
in his own universe but he sure can give
everyone a run for their money this is a
character with a slew of Super Saiyan
forms that progressively get more and
more broken and cheating death isn't
exactly anything special for him I think
that a list of the most overpowered main
characters really deserves to close out
with one of the biggest cultural icons
of them all one who can defeat God's
mind you also one who seems to have no
upper seating in terms of how strong he
can really get
oh that was a handful wasn't it now I'd
love to know which characters would make
your version of this list who are your
top 20 overpowered main characters tell
me down in the comments section and go
check the channel for more content if
lists like this to your liking don't
forget to check out snowbreak
containment Zone through the link in the
description it seeks to combine a lot of
what we love about anime this looks to
be the next major hit in the mobile game
world you better be there when it
happens thank you for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video and I'll be
waiting for you in the next one see ya